i know
i know you love me tonight but will you
respect me in the morning
hey how how about this how about this
weather where
we're having out here in california in
the wild
may the sewers of rangoon back up into
your breakfast
this is richard how i love to be
president nixon
i want to tell you you know my fellow
americans
i just got back from hollywood where i
was working on a new motion picture
it's called planet of the tapes
i know the the that you know
that that i know that the that you know
and if you knew that i knew that
then then then we both would know if we
[Applause]
knew
don i'm a nice guy
[Applause]
all right king facal of saudi arabia so
so glad you could come hope you find the
parking place for your camel
anyway may i say something johannes can
i say this from the bottom of my heart
you gotta be the ugliest king i've ever
seen in my life
your face was a building and be
condemned
maxi time uh i love you
you're you're a wonderful little guy
you're a little taggier
i know you got a lot on your mind but
try and remember next time no starts in
the car huh
feed out pastor what are you doing here
tonight you hockey park
what'd you do get a note from the
russians saying you could take the night
off
incidentally is that a bear to you
sticking your head under your armpit
now i've done a lot of politicians over
the years i've done people like
like bill clinton who wrote me a lot of
great material
[Music]
and george w bush i don't know why the
american people are
picking on me
i haven't done anything
my name is bert lekiston
[Music]
i'd like to tell you a few things but my
good friend kurt douglas
kirk and i made five motion pictures
together as far as i'm concerned there
were five too many
let's go back to the beginning kirk was
born
in amsterdam new york at school at the
age of six
his screen image was already beginning
to take shape
when asked to read before the class kirk
said
see dick run
see jane run see
dick and jane at spot and puff run
see dick run after puff see dick catch
up the puff
sea pups scratch dick
she dick grandpa
[Laughter]
in the face
[Applause]
before i start speaking tonight i
i would like to say something
[Music]
i am delighted to be here but then at my
age hell i'm delighted to be anywhere
i have to be honest i haven't played
golf in years
as a matter of fact the last time i
played
was with arnie and lee benedict arnold
and general lee
and i regretted that my god those
those wooden balls were murder
no i i stand corrected i did play
nine holes of golf last spring with tip
o'neill
and um well i regretted that game too
as a matter of fact at one point i hit
the ball
up on the green about 50 feet from the
cup
and when i was bent over trying to make
the pot
i made the mistake of saying my god if i
get this in i'll die
with that tip o'neill picked up the ball
and said mr president
that's a gimme
[Music]
[Applause]
now andy rooney of 60 minutes touches
all generations the past the present and
hopefully the future
and he's always asking questions a
little annoying at times but always
asking questions
here's a few things that bother me
why do they sterilize needles for lethal
injection
[Applause]
why did kamikaze pilots wear helmets
i don't understand that at all here's
something else
if an asp in the grass is a snake
then why is a grasp in the ass a goose
i don't get that at all
now now the way i understand it dr
kane said that miss marple said that the
knife that was found in the back of sir
reginald
what's the same knife that was used in
the kitchen by the maid winnie annie
that originally belonged to the gardener
ben harper used to scrape putty off the
solar wind
ah now now somebody's lying
here
and i suddenly realized that's how to do
johnny carson think of an ostrich
[Applause]
why please
a home run and a triple a first
baseman's glove
a catcher's glove and dolly parton
[Music]
[Applause]
name two big hits two big mets
thank you very much